please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god thank you thank you
i don't
i don't know if anyone got a glimpse of
uh the beginning of season one
but uh i went real hard by myself here i
looked nuts we were all nuts it was
september of 2020. we had this really
intimate setting
and yet one day we hoped that maybe we
could ever get here
so to our very first new york studio
audience thank you
so much
thank you thank you so much
it's a total dream
one i never thought we'd get to but here
we are in our season two
and it is such a privilege to be back in
um
my new hometown of new york i love it
here so much
i don't know if you can tell from my
accent but i'm from california
and um we're just celebrating everything
about hometowns we kicked off in my
hometown of los angeles and uh we're
here now and you know i just want to
celebrate the whole country
and
celebrate the fact that there is no
place like home and that emotional
storytelling for me is going to be a
huge thread for this season and we
actually get to leave the studio
so i want to take it as far vast and
wide as they'll possibly let us and here
we are starting in new york
[Music]